bonjour à tous bienvenue sur Public
Sénat pour les traditionnelles questions
d'actualité ce sont les dernières de
l'année 2014 nous allons vous les faire
vivre ici dans cette grande salle des
conférences du Sénat ça sera dans moins
d'un quart d'heure pour cette séance de
question d'actualité avant on va
débattre un petit peu de toute
l'actualité parlementaire politique avec
notre invité aujourd'hui jean-Mari
nogouen bonjour bonjour secrétaire
d'État en charge des relations avec le
Parlement je voudrais commencer par ce
qui s'est passé ce jeudi matin au Sénat
cette proposition de loi de
résolution pour donner un État
palestinien le vote pour du Sénat le
même que celui de l'assemblée il était
peut-être un petit peu plus serré je
vous propose deux petites réactions puis
vous allez réagir juste
après je pense que c'était utile que le
Sénat de la République est c'est un vote
qui amplifie ce qui a été fait par nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
un message fort pour le monde
et j'en suis
content c'est important parce que ici
jusqu'à même hier soir très
tard je pensais que nous étions
battu non pas par une non volonté des
sénateurs de la majorité sénatoriale
c'est des majorité plutôt UMP mais par
le fait qu'ils avaient été un peu
rechapitré dans une réunion avec le
nouveau président de l'UMP sur l'idée il
faut absolument que ce soit un vote
contre mais je souhaite que cette
reconnaissance soit utilisée par le
gouvernement français comme un
instrument pour la reconnaissance
mutuelle et pour la relance des
négociations le Sénat est partagé sur ce
vote mais il est uni sur l'objectif la
paix au Proche Orient qu'on arrête les
malheurs et qu'on arrête tous ces crimes
qui sont aujourd'hui produits voilà pour
ces réactions recueilllies au micro de
Jérôme Rabier Jean-Marie Logan il y
avait une certaine émotion on l'a vu il
y avait aussi un espoir politique mais
ce que j'ai envie de vous demander de la
part du gouvernement c'est ce que vous
allez faire de ce vote à partir de là
aujourd'hui vous savez que ce vote qui
est important que l'Assemblée et le
Sénat ai voté dans le même sens et en
même temps ce vote n'engage pas le
gouvernement le Gouvernement est
favorable à la perspective d'un État
palestinien mais il cherche à utiliser
comme le disait Jean-Pierre rafarin
cette perspective de la reconnaissance
cette volonté de la reconnaissance comme
étant un élément de la négociation
diplomatique donc c'est ce que nous
allons faire et Laurent Fabius s'est
exprimé assez longuement sur cette
question en disant que l'objectif de la
France était de parvenir à au Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU à une
résolution qui débouche vers une
conférence internationale parce que nous
savons bien nous sentons bien
aujourd'hui que les uns et les autres
ont beaucoup de difficultés à se parler
et encore plus à à conclure une paix
dans la sécurité parce que bien
évidemment il faut qu'il y ait de la
sécurité au proche- Orient aussi bien
pour un État palestinien viable que pour
Israël exactement parce que la droite ce
que réclamait la droite pour avoir une
sorte de consensus qui n'a pas été le
cas parce que la droite était prêt au
consensus avec la gauche c'était d'avoir
euh si vous la reconnaissance d'un
l'État israélien dans le même texte ce
qui a été refusé par la gauche non mais
l'état la France et l'Assemblée
nationale reconnaît l'État d'Israël il y
a pas de discussion euh simplement il
disait ce n'a pas été refusé par la
gauche qui s'est passé euh en dehors du
fait qu'il y avait peut-être à améliorer
le texte encore c'est que comme l'a dit
euh euh le sénateur de SC saint-enis euh
Gilbert Roger euh en fait monsieur
Sarkozi est intervenu sur les sénateurs
j'en suis le le témoin quasiment
physique euh pour faire retourner le
vote des sénateurs c'est avec une vision
très sectaire au lieu de de la volonté
des sénateurs j'en avais été témoin et
ce que dit Jean-Pierre rafarin le laisse
entendre c'est qu'il y avait une volonté
euh de façon équilibré d'arriver à un
accord général et Sarkozi s'y est opposé
pour des raisons politiciennes et euh
voilà c'est une c'est un témoignage
précis
c'est trouve que Nicolas Sarkozi a été
une fois de plus battu au Sénat puisque
il avait
souhaité que Monsieur Larché ne soit pas
élu et Monsieur Larcher a été élu il
avait souhaité qu'au groupe UNP ce soit
un de ses amis et ça a été quelqu'un
d'autre et là il souhaitait que la
résolution ne soit pas adoptée elle a
été adoptée décidément il a pas beaucoup
de succès avec les sénateurs mais en
tout état de cause euh en
l'occurrence oui je je considère
vraiment très choquant cette volonté
d'intervenir sur ce qui était une
volonté de se rassembler au plan
national et ce qui finalement s'est fait
on va passer un petit peu à la politique
intérieure cette fois bien sû euh on est
au lendemain de la présentation de la
loi sur la croissance dite loi Macron
euh le Premier ministre avait l'air bien
confiant lors de cette conférence de
presse de présentation vous pensez
aujourd'hui qu'il y a une majorité pour
ce texte à l'Assemblée comme au Sénat
sûr il va y avoir un débat il y a un
dialogue sû vous êtes sûr qu'il y a une
majorité ah oui je crois vraiment
d'abord ça fait maintenant presque 8
mois qu'on nous pose la question
peut-être pas toutes les semaines mais
tous les 15 jours à chais cha attendez
je vous réponds je vous constate vous
m'avez pas vous spécialement d'ailleurs
mais d'autres m'ont posé peut-être 10 20
fois 30 fois la question et à chaque
fois les choses se sont réalisé comme on
vous l'a dit et de façon très large bien
une majorité de gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale d'e façon R per parle bien du
du texte croissance he et mais moi je
vous parle de tous les textes sur
lesquels des questions ont été posées
sur à chaque fois nous vous avons donné
une réponse positif donc il y aura je
j'en suis certain une majorité autour de
ce texte de la même façon que je crois
qu'il y aura un dialogue constructif
entre l'ensemble des parlementaires
singulièrement les parlementaires de la
majorité et le Gouvernement sur ce texte
on parle surtout du travail du dimanche
vous avez vu qu'il y avait des crispions
énormes he sur sur ce travail du
dimanche je vous parle même pas de
Martine auri qui avait signé une tribune
dans Le Monde hier une régression que je
combattrai comment est-ce que vous avez
vous interprété ces propos vous
socialist je suis pas sûr qu' elle l'a
écrit sans doute avant de voir le texte
peut-être qu'elle était pas au CIN de
tout je savais pas que
écoutez je comprends pas bien comment
entre 5 semaines et 12 semaines enfin 5
dimanches et 12 dimanches il y a d'un
côté la gauche et de l'autre côté la
droite si vous voulez je pense que puis
je me suis laissé dire d'ailleurs que à
l il y avait aussi un débat y compris au
sein du Conseil mun et que Martin avait
pu envisager à certain moment de de
réfléchir à la question donc voilà c'est
une question pratique c'est pas une
question théorique c'est pas un projet
de société vous savez si on ouvrait les
12 di projet de société c'est pas un
débat de société non il y a un débat de
société sur la généralisation du travail
du dimanche mais c'est pas du tout ce
que propose ce texte il y a aujourd'hui
environ 7 millions de Français qui sont
amenés à pas tous les dimanches mais à
travailler un certain nombre de
dimanches les policiers les infirmières
les gens qui ouvrent les cinémas des
gens qui travaille en continu et cetera
bref 7 milli de français là ce dont on
parle ce dont on parle si on passait de
5 à 12 semaines ça concernerait 20000
personnes donc si vous voulez est-ce que
une affaire d'état c'est ce que vous
voulez dire ah non ni même une affaire
de projet de société c'est une gestion
pragmatique d'un certain nombre de
besoins comment est-ce que vous
comprenez qu'une partie je dis bien une
partie de du Parti socialiste en face
justement St la M de Lille la M de Paris
également écoutez oui mais la mère de
Paris elle défend des problèmes plus
particuliers parisiens plus précis
j'allais dire avec lesquel je suis pas
toujours d'accord encore que elle-même a
évolué sur cette question et donc elle
peut toujours évoluer mais euh euh ce
que je veux dire c'est que quand on
parle du travail du dimanche alors il y
a une simplification de langage on dit
on va le le texte Macron va proposer de
travailler le dimanche absolument pas il
y a absolument on maintient tout à fait
le travail le le le repos dominical et
donc il est question pour certains
commerces dans certaines conditions dans
certaines régions et avec une
compensation salariale de faire en sorte
que on passe de 5 à 12 dimanches ouvrés
dans l'année vous voyez encore une fois
ça concernerait 20000 personnes alors
qu'il y en a déjà 7 millions qui sont
amenés à travailler le dimanche j'ai une
dernière question pour vous sur ce thème
mais vous avez un peu répondu je
voudrais juste une confirmation
compromis éventuel à l'Assemblée
nationale comme au Sénat ça veut dire
pas de 493 possible c'est vote bloqué
sur ce texte écoutez non mais il y a une
constitution elle s'pp exclu rien du
tout je n'exclus rien du tout je vois
pourquoi je devrais exclure il y a tout
un tas de gouvernements ont utilisé
différents méthodes de procédure donc il
y a pas de raison mais je suis tout à
fait conscient qu'on peut arriver très
simplement à progresser sur ce texte
voilà question cette fois sur la loi sur
les régions qui arrivve bientôt au Sénat
notamment ce qu'on appelle la loi notre
ce sont les compétences c'est pas la loi
sur les région c'est sur les territoires
voà région on a déjà déà fa la carte des
régions qui éé voté à l'assemé nationale
qui y a quand même quelques difficultés
au Sénat vous l'avez compris et sur les
compétences cette fois vous avez décrété
l'urgence sur ce texte oui pour des
raisons pour permettre une lecture plus
rapide entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
mais nous avons dit en même temps que
nous souhaitons qu'il y ait deux
lectures donc il n'y a de lecture alors
pour vos téléspectateurs qui sont pas
toujours des familiers de la procédure
c'est la procédure la plus normale et la
plus comment on dirais- la plus la plus
lente d'un certain point de vue on
appelle ça l'urgence parce que
simplement on comprime les délais au
lieu d'avoir 6 semaines on aurait un peu
moins entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat
voilà et sur justement ces compétences
sur ces régions sur ce vote des régions
vous comprenez la rétisence ici des des
sénateurs ou c'est quelque chose qu'
aujourd'hui vous ne prenez plus en
compte vous avancez parce que vous avez
décrété l'urgence avancer on va avancer
mais on va avancer dans le dialogue je
crois que le gouvernement a écouté
depuis maintenant un an 8 mois il a
beaucoup entendu ce qu'avait à dire les
uns les autres je pense qu'on peut
raisonnablement arriver vers un texte
qui rassemble très largement les
parlementaires j'ai encore deux
questions avant de vous laisser il a un
peu de retard lors des questions
d'actualité j'en profite donc pour vous
poser ces deux petites questions à
l'Assemblée nationale d'une député a
fait un rapport sur les 35 heures elle a
dit que dans ce rapport il a été
efficace contre le chômage et notamment
moins coûteuse que les autres politiques
de l'emploi vous êtes d'accord avec C
terme employé oui il y a eu ça a été
déjà décrit c'était un rapport qui bon
euh il y a eu une création de 300000
emplois ind discutablement voilà bien et
donc après il y a une appréciation
globale de la problématique du coût du
travail d'une part est-ce que ça
renchéri le coût du travail d'une façon
comment dirais-je exagérée à un moment
on est en compétition avec l'Allemagne
notamment et deuxièmement est-ce que ça
introduit de trop grandes rigidités bon
voilà il y a toujours eu un débat et
d'ailleurs ce débat est largement
dépassé puisque il y a eu même si on
maintient les 35 heur heure durée légale
du tra vous savez comme moi qui a
eu différents assouplissements qui
permettent aujourd'hui de travailler et
notamment l'accord sur la flexibilité de
l'emploi signé l'année dernière qui sera
prorogé dans les mois et les années qui
viennent on attend la sonnerie de la
cloche qui va bientôt donner le top
départ évidemment de ces questions
d'actualité alors que Emmanuel Macron le
ministre de l'Économie fait son entrée
dans la salle des conférences on a vu
aussi manuel Vals qui est là j'avais
juste une dernière très courte question
parceil y a quand même un petit peu de
retard que j' aille au ban oui vous avez
des bonnes notes à l'école euh c'était
inégal à la fin ça s'est plutôt bien
passé mais euh voilà pour pour ou contre
la suppression des notes non mais la
suppression des not n'ayez pas c'est
c'est on va vers une évolution où on
sera moins dans la stigmatisation des
élèves et ça je suis à fond pour en tant
que parents ayant connu ça mes enfants
n'ont plus l'âge d'aller à l'école mais
franchement arrêtons de stigmatiser et
de croire que c'est par une mécanique
faiter récompenses que les choses
avancent dans l'éducation des enfants il
faut encourager tous nos enfants y
compris les meilleurs mais y compris les
moins bons à réussir c'est comme ça
c'est la pédagogie qui fait avancer
notre pays nous sommes nous avons la
pédagogie stigmatisante la plus retardée
de tous les pays tous les organismes
mondiaux de pédagogie nous disent mais
que fait la France sur le sujet donc
écoutons un petit peu soyons un petit
peu pragmatique encore une fois je vous
laisse retourner évidemment sur le banc
des ministres merci beaucoup Jean-Marie
legouen secrétaire d'État en charge des
relations avec le Parlement merci
d'avoir répondu en direct aux questions
de Public Sénat on va bientôt aller
écouter les traditionnelles questions
d'actualité au Sénat on voit que Gérard
Larchet a pris place au plateau donc ça
ne serait bien sûr pas tardé à commencer
les questions cette semaine alors il y
aura beaucoup de questions autour de la
loi Macron il y a notamment Pierre
Laurent le secrétaire national du Parti
communiste qui a l'atention de poser sa
question sur le projet de loi pour la
croissance et l'activité question à
Emmanuel Macron une autre question sera
posé par le président du groupe
socialiste ici au Sénat c'est Didier
Guillaume et autre voyez trois questions
qui seront posées à Emmanuel Macron pas
moins de trois questions notamment sur
les professions réglementées on en
parlera bien évidemment ensemble après
la séance des questions d'actualité dans
on refait la séance mais on parlera
également on reviendra sur le vote de la
résolution qui a eu lieu ce matin au
Sénat qui favorise donc la résolution
pour le la reconnaissance d'un État
palestinien un vote pour de la part du
Sénat comme celui de l'Assemblée
nationale on en parlait tout à l'heure
avec Jean-Marie leouen qui a salué ce
vote et qui aura pour terme évidemment
une résolution à l'ONU qui sera défendue
par le ministre des Affaires étrangères
Laurent fabus d'ici à peu près quelques
quelques mois c'est un peu ce que nous
disait Jean-Marie legouen tout à l'heure
voilà pour les questions d'actualité qui
vont bientôt démarrer avec un peu de
retard nous ditons Gard larch qui est au
plateau les sénateurs sont entrés dans
l'émycl la sonne c'est parti sé est
reprise à tout à l'heure Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
mais mes chers collègues nous venons
d'apprendre que le lycée français de
Kabou a été touché par un attentat
commis par un kamicas qui a tué sans
doute au moins une personne n'est fait
d'autres victimes cet acte aussi igno
que l'âche ne peut que susciter notre
indignation et je ne doute pas qu'en cet
instant notre pensée à tous va aux
victimes et à leur
famille l'ordre du jour appelle donc les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
retransmises en direct sur France 3 et
et et Public Sénat la parole est à notre
collègue Jean de zessard pour le groupe
écologique vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue question à Madame la Ministre
des outremires sur le plan de lutte
contre le suicide en Guyane madame la
ministre le 16 avril 2014 ma collègue
Aline archambo vous a interrogé sur
l'importance du taux de suicide des
populations autochtones en
Guyane ce taux est en effet largement
supérieur à celui enregistré en
métropole dans l'Hexagone on compte un
décès par suicide par an pour 5000
habitants ce qui est déjà très important
un des plus importants au niveau
européen sur le haut
Maroni lieu de vie des Amérindiens c'est
un pour 200 habitants selon
l'association ad action pour le
développement l'éducation et la
recherche soit 25 fois plus qu'en
métropole madame la ministre vous aviez
alors répondu que le gouvernement
avançait dans l'intérêt des populations
autochtones vous aviez rappelé la
poursuite du plan préfectoral de janvier
2011 de lutte contre le suicide la
création d'écoles de proximité la prise
en compte des langues amérindiennes dans
l'éducation pour lutter contre
laulturation source de malêtre pour ces
populations 8 mois après cette question
le moment est venu de dresser un premier
bilan de l'action de gouvernement
avez-vous des chiffres précis sur les
sur le suicide des Amérindiens d'après
nos information qui ont motivé cette
question le mois dernier au moins trois
suicides d' d'amerindiens ont été
recensés deux dans la commune de Camopi
et un dans le village d'antkum pat le
problème est donc moin d'être résolu
pourtant il existe des solutions en
janvier en juillet 2013 à la suite d'une
mission d'information de la commission
des affaires sociales sur le système de
prévention du suicide au Québec la
délégation a rédigé un rapport
identifiant plusieurs bonnes pratiques
que le Québec avait mis en place il
s'agissait entre autres d'un travail
suivi sur les causes en partenariat avec
des universitaires des sciences humaines
d'un service d'écoute téléphonique très
réactif d'un suivi personnalisé par des
agents de liaison et de la mise en place
d'un réseau de sentinelle au sein de la
population votre question ces mesures
ont fait leur preuve de 2000 à 2010 il y
a eu une diminution de 38 % du taux de
suicide madame la ministre mes questions
le plan de 2011 est-il efficasse sinon
pouvez-vous l'améliorer voir le changer
et quand voici mes questions merci pour
vous répondre la parole est à Madame
George Paul enevin ministre des outr
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président
permettez-moi avant de répondre à la
question du sénateur de zessa d'adresser
moi aussi au nom du gouvernement mes
condoléances aux familles de la Réunion
qui ont été endeillé par un grave
accident qui a tué cinq jeunes par
ailleurs c'est vrai que vous posez une
question sur un sujet qui nous préoccupe
fortement la question du suicide chez
les Amérindiens et je dois vous dire que
effectivement nous sommes préoccupés par
le nombre important de suicides de
jeunes et d'ailleurs de moins jeunes
dans cette communauté ce qui montre les
difficultés d'accès à la modernité quand
on a un mode de vie traditionnel comme
celui de ces personnes donc aujourd'hui
nous avons relancé sur suite à la
question de Madame archambau nous avons
relancé les procédures qui étaient en
cours à la à la préfecture de la Guyane
pour que on puisse avoir un dialogue
plus approfondi avec ces populations les
équipes de santé se déplacent dans les
sites isolés équipe de psychiatrie
adulte et
pédopsychiatrie mais je crois que donc
des groupes de travail sur et de parole
avec ces jeunes mais je suis d'accord
sur le fait que pour l'instant le le
renouvellement de suicide nous montre
que nous sommes encore loin du compte
par conséquent nous
allons désigner une mission de
l'Inspection Générale qui ira sur place
et fera le bilan de ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui par ailleurs dès que je vais
en guyan prochainement j'ai prévu de
rencontrer le Conseil Consultatif des
peuples bchinangé et amérindien de
manière à ce que eux aussi soient mieux
associés à la politique àener pour que
ces populations soient mieux prises en
compte le il y a un interlocuteur a
titré des communes de l'intérieur de
manière à ce que les les problèmes que
rencontrent ces populations et notamment
les jeunes puissent faire l'objet d'un
suivi régulier par ailleurs on avait
souligné la question de l'accès à
l'école puisque dans ces communes
enclavées trop souvent les jeunes pour
être scolarisé doivent quitter leur
famille et aller en internat à des
distances considérables donc nous nous
sommes en train de développer avec le
recteur de la Guyane la possibilité
d'avoir des écoles au plus près de ces
jeunes de manière à ce qu'il ne soit pas
trop perdu mais vraiment comme c'est un
sujet qui importe je crois que si il y a
un groupe de travail à monter là-dessus
je serais contente que maximum de
sénateurs puissent y être associés merci
Madame la
Ministre la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre Laurand pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyens vous avez la
parole monsieur le
sénateur merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron vous avez présenté hier votre
projet de loi ce projet de loi consacre
la déréglementation sociale à tous les
étages conformément une nouvelle foi au
vœux du mdeef pourtant il y a quelques
jours dans un élan de sincérité aussitôt
réprimé vous avez reconnu vous-même
l'échec du PACT de responsabilité
inspiré par les mêmes alors c'est ma
première question pourquoi persister
dans
l'erreur pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre
une loi Fourtout sur laquelle d'ailleurs
le Conseil d'État ém des réserves
importantes qui n'a en fait qu'un seul
fil conducteur la déréglementation du
code du travail et de la régulation
publique pourquoi plus d'asservicement
encore des salariés aux exigences
patronales avec la généralisation du
travail du dimanche et du soir car vous
le savez bien en l'espèce le volontariat
n'est que de la blague pourquoi
libéraliser le transport en autocar
contre le développement des petites
lignes ferroviaires pourquoi alors que
la rente autoroutière eng grresse les
grands concessionnaires du BTP depuis la
privatisation ne pas renationaliser les
autoroutes pourquoi privatiser les
aéroports de Nice et de Lyon après celui
de Toulouse pourquoi privatiser nos
entreprises de défense JAT et
Nexter votre loi n'est qu'une loi pour
la liberté
d'exploiter une loi contre les libertés
de 99 % de la
population pourquoi par exemple et
encore la mise en cause des prudommes la
dépénalisation du délit d'entrave le
pouvoir unilatéral des patrons de fixer
l'ordre des licenciements dans les PSE
toute mesure qui figure dans votre
projet pourquoi l'insécurité juridique
pour tous avec la mise en concurrence
des professions réglementées et une
justice surmesure pour l'entreprise avec
un statut inédit d'avocat en entreprise
pourquoi rien contre le recours au
travailleurs détachés et seulement des
mots contre le travail détaché illégal
alors même que vous le savez c'est le
principe de la directive des
travailleurs détachés qui est en cause
je vous le dis monsieur le ministre
votre loi va diviser la France diviser
les travailleurs et diviser la
gauche vous poursuivez sur une voie qui
trahit vos électeurs et cela aura des
conséquences
dans tous les rendez-vous électorau à
venir il faut conclure j'invite les
sénateurs de gauche je vais conclure
merci tous ceux qui n' qui ont l'égalité
au cœur à ne pas accepter ceè recul de
civilisation monsieur le ministre je
vous demande je vous demande
d'entendre la colère qui monte déjà dans
toute la gauche et dans le monde
syndical et je vous demande de retirer
votre projet de loi avant qu'il ne soit
trop
tard pour répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Emmanuel Macron ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et du
numérique vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur j'ai envie de vous
dire parce que à la série de vos
pourquoi mais la caricature est telle
que je me dois de vous répondre avec un
peu de précision je ne sais je ne sais
de quoi vous parler je ne sais
d'ailleurs même pas si vous avez lu le
texte qui a été déposé hier en conseil
des ministres puisque vous faisiez
référence vous faisiez référence vous
faisiez référence monsieur le sénateur
aux sanctions contre les travailleurs
détachés il y a bien une disposition qui
augmente les sanctions contre c dernier
dans le texte donc vous ne l'avez pas lu
alors maintenant monsieur le sénateur de
quelle France parlez-vous et quelle
gauche voulez-vous parce que c'est ça la
bonne question la France dont nous
parlons elle travaille le dimanche à 30
% des cas elle travaille et elle
consomme le dimanche et elle travaille
déjà aujourd'hui trop souvent sans
compensation et bien ce projet de loi il
permet de donner plus de liberté sur le
terrain et de mettre partout c'est
possible de la compensation ça c'est de
la vraie justice et c'est de l'égalité
monsieur le sénateur ce ne sont pas des
grands mots qu'on donne dans ces lieux
la France Monsieur dans laquelle nous
vivons vous et moi c'est une France dans
laquelle il y a des accès au territoire
qui sont insuffisants c'est une France
dans laquelle on ne peut pas se déplacer
comme on veut quand on n pas l'argent
quand on peut pas prendre le train en
effet ou qu'on n pas son véhicule
particulier ouvrir les lignes d'autocar
c'est une mesure de justice et c'est
aussi une mesure d'activité cela se fait
chez nos voisins et c'est une bonne
mesure dès ce matin des Industri du
secteur se sont engagés à créer des
emplois félicitez-vous de cela
félicitez-vous de cela la gauche
monsieur le sénateur qui est derrière ce
projet ça n'est pas la gauche en effet
qui regarde le passé de la France qui
veut une France qui n'existe plus c'est
une gauche qui regarde la France telle
qu'elle est alors peut-être qu'elle ne
vous plaît pas mais c'est la France
telle qu'elle est dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui et dans laquelle la
véritable gauche elle doit recréer des
égalités d'accès elle doit recréer plus
de capacités pour les français et les
Français elle doit recréer plus de
droits réels et les droits réels
monsieur le sénateur ça n'est pas
forcément de l'argent public ça n'est
pas forcément les vieilles lunes c'est
en effet des vraies mesures et vous
parliez des prudesommes et je veux finir
là-dessus sur les prudommes mais de quoi
peut-on se félicité c'est une justice
qui dure trop longtemps dont les
résultats sont incertains qui est
profondément injuste par son
fonctionnement alors oui c'est une belle
idée mais c'est une belle idée qui ne
marche pas donc nous devons faire
fonctionner mieux cette belle idée nous
en gardons le principe paritaire et
c'est ce qu'avec françoisen et
christianbir nous avons voulu mais nous
en réduirons les délais nous améliorons
la formation des juges pour que pour les
salariés plus fragil pour que pour les
PME le droit du travail soit moins
instable fonctionne mieux plus d'égalité
plus d'égalité plus de justice c'est ça
la
gauche la
paroleant Monsieur Didier Guillaume pour
le groupe socialiste vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur
le monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
monsieur le Premier ministre nous
l'avons vu à travers la question qui
vient d'être posée et nous le savons
beaucoup trop de Français souffrent dans
notre pays il souffrent parce qu'il y a
encore beaucoup trop d'égalité C
inégalités il a beaucoup ingalité ces
inégalités sont économiques elles sont
sociales et elles sont
territoriales depuis 2 ans ce
gouvernement a déjà fait beaucoup mais
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui nous devons
affirmer Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous l'avez fait hier dans un discours
que la lutte contre les inégalités doit
être au cœur de la démarche du
gouvernement en tout cas la lutte contre
les inégalités est au cœur du mouvement
de gauche dans ce pays vous avez
souhaité placer la deuxème partie de ce
quinquena dans la lutte contre les
inégalités donc en citoyen le constate
et Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie
vient de le dire il constate que la
France est bloquée il constate que la
France est figée et dans un sondage qui
a été publié dans un grand hebdomadaire
du soir que l'ont dit cet après-midi 84
% des Français selon un sondage CSA
soutiennent l'idée de réforme
soutiennent l'idée de changement et
soutiennent l'idée de rénovation de ce
pays ils sont prêts ils sont prêts à
accompagner les réforme à condition je
le pense que ces réformes soient justes
que ces réformes soient protectrices et
que ces réformes a du sens et de la
cohérence alors Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pouvez-vous éclairer le Sénat
sur la feuille de route de votre
gouvernement pour la lutte contre les
inégalités dans la deuxème partie de de
ce quinquena afin que nos concitoyens
trouvent des raisons objectives d'espéré
et retrouve de la confiance je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à Monsieur Manuel
Premier ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le Premier ministre monsieur le
Président Didier Guillaume nous avons en
effet présenté hier avec le ministre de
l'Économie et tous les ministres
concernés les grandes orientation du
texte de loi croissance et activité
c'est un texte le ministre vient de le
dire qui veut donner la capacité à notre
pays d'utiliser tous les leviers pour la
croissance la compétitivité
et l'investissement parce que s'il y a
une inégalité dans notre pays c'est
évidemment le chômage c'est donc un
texte pour l'emploi et le pouvoir
d'achat et je veux le dire de nouveau
très clairement ici ce texte n'a qu'un
seul objectif servir l'intérêt général
lever tous les blocages les freins à la
croissance en libérant les énergies et
en stimulant tout simplement l'économie
et pour cela il faut ouvrir un certain
nombre de secteurs il faut simplifier de
nombreuses procédures et pour cela il
faut permettre que des changements
concrets ai lieu pour la vie quotidienne
des Français nous devons lutter aussi
contre les conservatismes contre la
rente je suis d'ailleurs étonné qu'ici
même dans cette hémicycle sur la partie
gauche on privilégie la rente alors que
ce pays a besoin de libérer ce besoin a
ce pays a besoin de changer ce besoin ce
pays a besoin d'énergie depuis
l'élection de François Hollande nous
avons beaucoup agi et nous l'avons fait
contre cet immobilisme et nous le
faisons pour renforcer le pays nous le
faisons aussi pour l'égalité oui parce
que c'est une belle idée française c'est
une valeur fondamentale de la République
et c'est le sens de l'action de ce
gouvernement la retraite à 60 ans pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
le compte pénibilité qui fait débat la
modulation des allocations familiales
c'est ça aussi l'égalité et lorsque nous
refondons l'école de la République
lorsque nous créons 60000 postes
d'enseignants lorsque nous mettons en
œuvre les rimes scolaires c'est ça aussi
l'égalité lorsque nous créons des postes
de policiers de gendarmes de magistrats
détruits sous le quinquena précédent
c'est encore l'égalité car nous le
savons bien l'insécurité la délinquence
frappe les plus faibles et les plus
modestes de notre société mais en même
temps il faut regarder comme vous le
faites les choses en face notre pays
fait face à une montée des inégalités à
des fractures sociales et territoriales
la ministre valobelkassem pourrait
rappeler queles sont les chiffres
notamment donnés par les classements
PISA et l'effondrement au cours de ces
10 dernières années dans ce classement
dû aussi à l'absence de moyens et au
fait qu'on n' pas fait de l'école une
priorité et d'ailleurs Monsieur Laurent
d'une certaine manière en écho je vous
réponds quand vous ne votez pas le
budget de la nation qui pour la première
fois fois fait de l'école de la
République le premier budget de la
nation c'est là où je m'étonne sur les
leçons que vous voulez nous donner de
républicanisme de progrès et de gauche
mais il faut combattre ces inégalités
avant même qu'ell se crée à la racine et
c'est le travail que nous devons faire
dans le domaine du logement de la santé
et du et du logement et de l'école parce
que ce sont évidemment ses priorités
demain à l'occasion d'une réunion des
ministres et des secrétaires d'État je
présenterai l'agenda des réformes sur
les 2 ans qui viennent jusqu'à la fin du
quinquena pour mieux éclairer l'avenir
et je peux vous assurer et nous l'avons
bien démontré hier au fond c'était un
beau symbole le midi après le conseil
des ministres nous présentions cette loi
qui vise à redonner de la force à la
croissance et le soir je m'exprimais sur
l'égalité la gauche quand elle gouverne
elle marche sur ses deux jambes le
soutien la compétitivité et tout pour
l'égalité et c'est comme ça je crois que
nous retrouverons pleinement la
confiance des
Français merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la parole est maintenant à
Madame Anne-Catherine oisier pour le
groupe Union des démocrates et
indépendant Union centriste vous avez la
parole ma chère cè merci monsieur le
Président donc ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de l'écologie et
porte sur la création du Parc National
des Forêts de Champagne et de Bourgogne
qui suscite de vivre action localement
ce projet de parc national je le
rappelle était le premier projet de parc
de feuillu de plaine il a été présenté
par le Premier ministre de l'époque
lui-même Monsieur François Fillon en
2009 et il été adopté à plus de 90 % de
l'accord des des acteurs locaux
malheureusement cette version légitimée
sur le territoire n'a pas été prise en
compte en considération par les par vos
services par les services du ministère
de l'écologie au motif qu'elle n'était
pas suffisamment ambitieux
pourtant la préfiguration de ce parc
était le fruit d'une volonté à la fois
politique et locale de constituer un
premier grand parc national forestier de
de feuillu comp tenu notamment de la
présence importante de grands massifs
forestiers domino et de nombreuses
forêts communales et privées dans sa
lettre de recadrage adressé au GP du
futur parc national en février
2013 vos services sont remis en cause ce
projet initial et déclencher la la
colère de la profession agricole mais
aussi des forestiers publics et privés
en intégrant autoritairement dans la
zone de cœur des terres agricoles et des
forêts communales et privées la
difficulté madame la ministre vient que
de nombreuses exploitations agricoles
situées dans ces zones dites
intermétière donc à faible potentiel de
production ont une nécessité impérieuse
de recourir à des engrais des intrans
pour obtenir des rendements
indispensables à leur suivie elles ne
peuvent donc pas supporter des
contraintes environnementales
supplémentaire et en ce qui concerne les
communes forestières elles ont à de
nombreuses reprises affirmé leur
attachement au principe de libre
adhésion des forêt communal considérant
notamment l'importance de la filière
forêt-bois locale il n'est pas question
de fragiliser l'économie de ce
territoire et encore moins dans le
contexte actuel où l'on nous invite à
mobiliser encore plus de bois encore
plus de ressources pour mieux
approvisionner les entreprises local qui
se sont d'ailleurs manifestés il y a
quelques temps une telle initiative
serait donc préjudiciable madame la
ministre le mécontentement du monde
agricole et forestier est d'autant plus
profond actuellement que ces
revendications n'ont pas été entendu
lors des dernières instantces de
concertation c'est pourquoi en cette
période de consultation institutionnelle
je me fais l'écho des acteurs de ce
territoire pour vous demander une réelle
prise en compte des attentes
c'est-à-dire revoir à la baisse le
périmètre d'études et les surfaces des
terres agricoles du cœur respecter la
libre adhésion des communes forestières
et des propriétaires privés assurer
l'équilibre sing et identifier
clairement proportionner les contraintes
réglementaires qui vont être imposées
aux acteurs économiques de ce territoire
merci Monsieur pour vous répondre la
parole est à Monsieur Alain vidalis
secrétaire d'État chargé des transports
de la merère et de la pêcheavz la parole
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice mesdames
et messieurs sénateur sénatrices je vous
prie de bien vouloir excuser madame
Solen royale qui se trouve à Lima pour
la conférence sur le climat le principe
de création d'un parc national de forêt
plain dans les régions champagne Arden
et Bourgogne a été inscrit dans la loi
Grenelle 1 avant la création du parc le
projet doit passer par une étape de
prise en considération mené par un
groupement d'intérêt public constitué à
cet effet le GP a ouvert une large
consultation locale sur ce projet cette
consultation doit s'achever en janvier
prochain le GP devant délibérer en
février 2015 à l'issue une consultation
de niveau national sera ouverte avant
proposition de l'arrêté de prise en
considération à la signature du premier
ministre en l'état aucune décision n'est
prise sur la réglementation des
activités forestières dans le cœur du
futur parc bien que la loi dispose que
ces activités soient forcément
réglementées le projet du GIP de recréer
une filière bois locale approvisionné
localement de manière à ce que le bois
soit mieux valorisé tout en
reconnaissant que la production sera
inférieur l'Union des communes
forestières de Côte d'Or que vous
présidez participe d'ailleurs à une
étude sur la valorisation de la
ressource bois sur le territoire du
futur parc le périmètre du cœur devra en
ce qui le concerne être cohérent et
fonctionnel il ne peut donc être
constitué uniquement de forêt domanial
ce qui donnerait un périmètre en pot de
léopard il restera toutefois en très
grande majorité composé de forêt ce qui
conduit à relativiser considérablement
les craintes que certains agriculteurs
pourraient avoir sur leur activité les
des espaces agricoles qui seraient le
cas échéant inclus dans le cœur pour
être des secteurs de prairies humid dans
les secteurs de sources à Fort enjeux
écologique la réglementation du cœur
n'aura en tout état de cause pas
vocation à interdire l'agriculture ni
d'ailleurs la chasse la réglementation
applicable devra se faire en étroite
concertation avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes certaines communes par
ailleurs membres du GP entendent sortir
du GP en espérant que ceci va leur
permettre de sortir du projet c'est une
appréciation erronée puisque le GP n'est
que l'organe d'organisation de la
concertation et que la fixation du
périmètre est totalement indépendant de
ces statuts la création d'un parc est
une chance et d'ailleurs deux parcs en
France celui de Guadeloupe et des piréné
ont été classés au sommet comme de la
liste verte de l'Union internationale
des pares ce qui montre bien que pour
certains territoires c'est une vraie
chance merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à madameatherine och pour le
groupe Union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
la Ministre de des affaires sociales de
la santé et du droit des femmes madame
la ministre depuis des semaines le monde
de la santé est en ébullition en effet
la fin de l'année 2014 et le début 2015
verront des mouvements de grève qui sont
par les les professions médicales et qui
inquiète nos concitoyens vous avez face
à vous un front Unis qui a fait assez
RAR pour pour le souligner un front
unique qui associe les syndicats de
médecins qui associe les médecins
généralistes les médecins spécialistes
quel que soit le leur secteur
conventionnel d'activité qui associe le
secteur privé et le secteur public qui
associe des médecins exerçant en
province ou en région parisienne et je
n'oublie pas les urgentistes ce front
uni est assez rare pour que le Conseil
de l'Ordre et que l'Académie de médecine
s'en soit fait l'écho mais ce n'est pas
un mouvement de grande corporatime
madame les ministre c'est bien un
mouvement d'inquiétude profonde du monde
médical face à certaines dispositions de
la loi de santé publique inquiétude des
syndicats de médecins face à la
généralisation du tiers payant et à la
revalorisation de la consultation du
médecin généraliste inquiétude de
l'hospitalisation privée quant à ses
financements et à une recentralisation
des pouvoirs autour des ARS inquiétude
des chirurgiens des cliniques des
internes des hôpitaux publices qui sont
en grève illimité et qui s'inquiètent
pour leur avenir et si nous ne pouvons
que souscrire un projet de loi qui en
effet remet le patient au cœur du du
parcours de soins qui axe sur la
prévention et qui bien sûr souhaite
réduire les inégalités certaines
disposition de ce texte madame la
ministre risque de mettre à mal notre
système français de santé notre modèle
français de santé qui certes il doit
s'adapter au défi actuel doit continuer
à reposer sur ces deux piliers public et
privé la grogne est profonde les
crispations sont importantes or le
dialogue semble rompu mais les
professionnels de santé le monde médical
attendent de vous des signaux forts de
confiance comptez-vous les leur donner
merci pour vous répondre la parole à
Madame Laurence Rossignol secrétaire
d'État charge de la famille des
personnes ager de l'autonomie vous avez
la parole madame la ministre madame la
sénatrice Catherine de roche je vous
remercie d'abord d'excuser Marie
soltouren qui ne pouvait pas être là
cette après-midi le projet de loi
relatif à la santé est d'abord une loi
pour les patients et une loi contre les
inégalités les inégalités de santé et
les inégalités d'accès aux soins lutter
contre les inégalités c'est d'abord
miser sur la prévention parce qu'il y a
ceux qui grâce à leur héritage social ou
culturel grâce à des conditions de vie
plus favorables ont une hygiène de vie
qui les protège de la maladie et puis il
y a ceux qui sont frappés le plus plus
tôt plus souvent et plus durement alors
nous renforçons éducation et information
sanitaire et nous créons un médecin
traitant pour les enfants lutter contre
les inégalités c'est aussi accorder aux
patients un droit à l'information parce
qu'il y a ceux qui savent s'orienter
dans le système de soins et ceux qui s'y
perdent alors nous créons un numéro de
garde unique pour trouver un
professionnel de santé près de chez soi
et à toute heure et nous reconnaissons
aussi dans la loi le rôle des
associations de pour la première fois et
valorisons leurs initiatives sur le
terrain nous créons l'action dans de
groupe en santé lutter contre les
inégalité c'est faire tomber aussi les
barrières financières parce qu'il y a
ceux qui peuvent consulter leurs
médecins sans se poser de question ceux
qui peuvent acquitter le prix de la
consultation et ceux pour qui la
nécessité d'avancer les frais est un
obstacle infranchissable alors nous
mettons en effet en place le tier payant
de manière progressive dès 2015 pour nos
concitoyens qui sont sous le seuil de
pauvreté et ensuite généralisé en 2017
madame la sénatrice cet objectif de
lutte contre les inégalités est très
largement partagé ou pour le moins
devrait l'être le gouvernement a pour
autant entendu ici ou là des points qui
suscitent des inquiétudes chez les
professionnel il s'agit pour une grande
part de malentendu ou de contevérité que
marieoltouren entend lever un à un c'est
pourquoi elle reçoit à nouveau les
représentants des médecins libéraux pour
aborder avec eux l'ensemble de ses
points et avancé vous le voyez madame la
sénatrice la volonté du gouvernement est
claire il s'agit de lutter d'abord
contre les inégalités pour que notre
système de santé renoue avec sa promesse
originelle être accessible à tous c'est
dans ce sens que nous entendons avancer
en levant les malentendus et les
inquiétudes mais en gardant le
cap
merci la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
Colomba pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue mon le
ministre intérieur vous le savez pour
vous être rendu à la satisfaction
générale je dois dire à La Londe et à
hier le 29 novembre dernier leev mais
aussi les Pyrénées Orientales l'ude
l'éau et laavyon viennent de subir de
nouvelles inondations catastrophiques
quatre morts dans le Var et des dégâts
du niveau de ceux de janvier 2014 qui
ont été estimés alors à 200 millions
d'euros plus généralement vous l'avez
constater en matière d'inondation notre
dispositif d'intervention et de secours
donne satisfaction
par
contre par contre on ne peut on peut en
dire autant en matière de prévention et
de gestion de l'après-crise s'agissant
notamment de la réparation des dommages
de l'indemnisation des personnes et de
l'aide aux collectivités certes une
procédure de reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle d'urgence
vient-elle d'être mise en place depuis 6
mois vous l'avez d'ailleurs utilisé en
annonçant l'engagement une réflexion
pour moderniser le dispositif de soutien
de l'État aux collectivités je cite le
compte-rendu du conseil des ministres du
3 décembre dernier or monsieur le
ministre une telle réflexion a été
engagée au Sénat depuis 2 ans elle a
même abouti grâce au soutien alors du
gouvernement à l'inscription dans la loi
de dispositions essentielle en matière
de prévention le Sénat a aussi adopté en
première lecture il y a un an un
ensemble de dispositions relatives en
particulier à la gestion de
l'après-crise et à la sensibilisation de
la population qui est un véritable
problème je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
elle na toujours pas pu être inscrite à
l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée nationale
d'où ma question ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il serait opportun qu'elle puisse
l'être un jour et que la réflexion dont
vous ressentez vous-même la nécessité
puisse ainsi se nourrir de la
contribution du Parlement ce qui
d'ailleurs a pu être fait lors de la loi
maptam ce qui montre que c'est possible
alors Monsieur le Ministre ma question
est simple est-ce qu'on continue à
déplorer où est-ce qu'on
avance pour vous répondre la parole est
à Monsieur casenu ministre de
l'Intérieur vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre monsieur le sénateur Colomba
vous traitez là d'une question que vous
connaissez bien puisque vous avez été
l'auteur d'un rapport parlementaire qui
a fait l'objet d'une proposition de loi
présentée au Sénat à l'automne 2013 et
qui traitait de la question de la lutte
contre les inondations et des mesures
préventives à prendre je me suis rendu
comme vous l'avez signalé à l'instant
dans la commune de l'alonde les morts et
dans la commune d'hier il y a de cela
une quinzaine de jours pour constater
les dégâts effectués tu est engendré par
les inondations un an après que des
dégâts très importants avaient déjà été
occasionnés et pour définir avec les
élus les modalités d'indemnisation pour
répondre très précisément à votre
question trois problèmes se posent le
premier problème est celui des fonds qui
sont destinés à indemniser les
collectivités locales mais aussi les
exploitations agricoles mais aussi les
entrepris lorsqu'il y a des inondations
ou des calamités de grande ampleur il y
a deux fonds un fond calamité un fond
catastrophe naturelle je propose que
l'on fusionne ces fonds et qu'aucun gel
ne s'applique à ces fonds de telle sorte
à ce qu'en fin de gestion notamment on
puisse allouer à toutes les
collectivités locales les sommes dont
elles ont besoin pour faire face aux
travaux notamment aux travaux de
réparation de lutte contre les
inondations et on a pu constater
ensemble à la l les morts que quelques
mois après la décision du gouvernement
de financer les procédures
administrative avait bloqué
l'attribution des fonds la deuxième
décision qu'il faut prendre c'est une
décision d'augmentation du plafond euh
des avances qui sont effectué par l'État
au collectivité local pour leur
permettre avant présentation des
factures de pouvoir financer leurs
opérations porter ce taux de 15 à 25 %
c'était une d'ailleurs de votre
proposition je crois serait une bonne
manière d'assurer le financement dans de
bonnes conditions des travaux trème
point lorsque les dégâts sont
occasionnés il faut 6 mois d'enquête par
les inspections générales de l'IGF du
ministère de
l'écologie l'inspection générale de la
l'administration du ministère de
l'intérieur d'autres inspections avant
que le droit indemnisation ne s'ouvre
c'est beaucoup trop d'inspections
mobilisé sur un laps de temps beaucoup
trop long il faut simplifier raccourcir
pour que l'indemnisation arrive beaucoup
plus vite enfin dernier point il faut
que lorsqu'il y a des travaux qui
relèvent des cours d'eau ou de la lutte
contre les inondations on trouve un bon
équilibre entre les règles de
l'environnement et l'urgence c'est ce
sur quoi euh la ministre de l'écologie
envoyé une inspection à la long morts et
c'est sur quoi le gouvernement entend en
plus de la simplification des procédures
engager une réflexion au profit des
collectivités territoriales sur tous ces
sujets votre contribution monsieur le
sénateur aura été très
décisive merci la parole est à Monsieur
Yannick vugrognard pour le groupe
socialiste vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues lundi 1er décembre à créteille
un couple se faisait sauvagement
agresser dans son appartement et la
femme était violée le caractère
antisémite de cet acte auieux est avéré
au-delà d'une évidente compassion qui
s'impose à l'égard de ces personnes je
considère que c'est aussi notre
démocratie et notres républiques qui
sont insulté et le socle de nos valeurs
qui est bafoué la période que nous
traversons est socialement et
économiquement particulièrement
difficile il y en eu d'autres avec les
conséquences dramatiques imprimées dans
chacune de nos mémoires l'histoire ne se
répète pas diront certains sans doute
mais il arrive qu'elle bégai aussi
prenons garde dans ce contexte si
particulier prenons garde au discours
parfois empreint de populisme qui cible
les bouqus émissaires de tout ce qui va
mal y compris lorsqu'ils prétendent
magner l'humour le risque de
normalisation de propos intolérants nous
impose une vigilance de chaque instant
car ce sont ces propos qui peuvent aussi
armer des mains à l'esprit malveillant
ou fragile depuis le début de cette
année la France a subi une hausse de 91
% des actes antisémites ce chiffre à lui
seul fait froid dans le dos et ce mal
qui ronge notre pays exige une
nécessaire prise de conscience
individuelle tout autant qu'un
indispensable sur saau collectif
monsieur le ministre l'aspect répressif
va de soi mais il n'est pas suffisant
compte tenu des évolutions d'agression
antisémite et raciste que nous
constatons ne pensez-vous pas qu'il soit
nécessaire d'engager notamment avec avec
le ministère de l'Éducation nationale
mais aussi les mondes médiatiques et
associatifs une prise de conscience de
cette dur réalité pour endiguer ce fléau
d'intolérance qui mine notre société
nous assistons trop fréquemment à une
forme de banalisation de l'horreur ou
encore à une indignation à géométrie
variable qui est ni acceptable ni
supportable or le racisme est un et la
lutte contre toute forme de racisme est
indivisible il me vient à l'esprit pour
conclure cette phrase inscrite à
l'entrée du village martyre d'Oradour
surglam l'humanité n'est pas un état à
subir mais une dignité à conquérir aussi
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens doit-il
comprendre que leur respect est dû à
tout un chacun que la liberté que
l'égalité et la fraternité ne sont et ne
seront jamais négociables dans notre
pays des droits de l'homme
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur
bernardu ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le sénateur vous venez avec
beaucoup de force de rappeler ce qu'est
l'antisémitisme et de rappeler aussi ce
que sont toutes les formes de haine qui
peuvent ronger la République de
l'intérieur et conduire peu à peu
parfois imperceptiblement à l'abandon
des valeurs qui font de la République et
auxquel collectivement nous tenons ici
dans cette hémicycle je me suis rendu à
créteille dimanche dernier pour
participer à la grande manifestation
organisé par la communauté juive de
créteille très blessé de l'acte abject
qu'avait subi euh un jeune couple à
créteille quelques jours auparavant j'ai
vu devant moi des hommes et des femmes
battu certaines étent révolté et il y
avait dans tous les regards une immense
tristesse et surtout une incommensurable
inquiétude l'inquiétude d'une communauté
qui sait que l'histoire a déjà parlé
qu'elle a parlé de façon monstrueuse
qu'elle a conduit à la déportation à
l'assassinat de millions de Juifs de
femmes de petits enfants de personnes
âgés dans les conditions que l'on sait
une communauté qui ne comprend pas alors
que tout cela est encore très récent
finalement que l'on puisse ne pas se
souvenir alors vous avez raison de dire
qu'il est important d'organiser une
mobilisation générale et cette
mobilisation générale est d'autant plus
importante que lorsque l'on voit ce qui
se diffuse notamment dans l'espace
numérique on se rend compte que bien des
DICS sont tombés et que parfois à
travers des tweets l'usage de la phrase
brève au service des idées courtes et
parfois mise au service de la haine et
donc il faut une mobilisation générale
cette mobilisation générale elle est
souhaitée par le Premier ministre qui
s'est à plusieurs reprises exprimé avec
beaucoup de force sur ce sujet et a
souhaité que la délégation
interministérielle à la lutte contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme lui soit
rattaché de manière à ce qu'il y ait une
véritable action interministérielle
milisant tous les ministères le
ministère de l'Intérieur bien entendu en
tant qu'il protège les lieux de culte en
tant que par l'intermédiaire des préfet
il porte plainte au titre de l'article
40 du code de procédure pénale à chaque
fois qu'un acte de haine raciste ou
antisémite est est constaté le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale qu'il porte
avec le ministère de l'Intérieur
ministère des Cultes l'ambition de
laïcité qui vise à assurer la protection
de tous les enfants de la République
autour de cette valeur et de toutes les
valeurs de la République dans l'école et
dans l'espace public public et le
ministère de la Jeunesse le ministère de
la Ville qui peuvent ensemble de façon
transversale porter un message de lutte
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
mais aussi il faut une mobilisation de
la société nous étions simplement 1500 à
créteille à d'autres époques nous
aurions été infiniment plus nombreux les
intellectuels se seraient exprimés les
forces sociales se seraient mises en
mouvement il faut donc par conséquent
que cette grande cause devienne la cause
de tous et il faut pour cela se rappeler
d'une belle formule celle de fr Fanon
qui disait lorsque vous entendez dire du
mal des Juifs tendez l'oreille on parle
de vous
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Didier
Mandelli pour le groupe Union pour un
mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègu ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'économie de l'industrie
et du numérique monsieur le ministre
hier c'était la journée de la justice
morte en France une grande première tous
les membres et collaborateurs des six
organisations professionnelles du droit
Conseil national des barreaux pour les
avocats Conseil supérieur du notariat
conseil national des greffiers des
tribunaux de commerce le Conseil
national des administrateurs
judiciaaires et des mataires judiciair
le Conseil national des commissaires
priseur judiciaaires et la Chambre
nationale des iciers de justice étent en
grève pour manifester contre votre
projet de loi pour la croissance et
l'activité les études et les cabinets
étaient fermés
cette mobilisation sans précédent
symbolise la colère froide qui se
généralise dans notre pays la tension
monte chaque jour un peu plus monsieur
le ministre dans votre projet de loi
Fourtout je reprends là l'expression du
premier secrétaire du Parti socialiste
Jean-Christophe cambadellis vous avez
l'ambition de redresser l'économie
française je partage cet objectif et je
l'encourage même selon vous l'un des
moyens pour y parvenir est de réformer
les professions réglementé notamment les
professions juridiques ces dernières
sont les garantes de la sécurité
juridique des Français
la plus grande vigilance s'impose donc
ce que l'on vous reproche monsieur le
ministre c'est votre précipitation et
une concertation à minima des
organisations professionnell concerné
l'étude d'impact de l'avantprjet de la
loi pour les professions juridiques est
une suite d'approximation et
d'interprétation de chiffres et de
fait le Conseil d'État a émis le 8
décembre dernier des réserves sur une
mesure phare de votre projet de loi la
liberté d'installation des notaires des
usussiers de justice et des commissaires
priseurs il estime qu'il a une rupture
caractérisée d'égalité de les charges
publiques d'autre part les
professionnels s'étonnent à juste titre
que le premier ministre est confié au
ministère de l'Économie de l'Industrie
et du numérique la tâche de réformer les
professions juridiques réglementées et
non au ministère de la Justice je vous
demande donc aujourd'hui d'écouter les
professionnels du droit en France pour
cela Monsieur le Ministre donnez-vous du
temps pour un dialogue constructif c'est
la seule méthode qui permettra d'engager
une modernisation attendue de l'exercice
de ces professions règlementé pourquoi
Monsieur le Ministre ne pas retirer de
votre projet de loi tous les articles
concernant les professions juridiques et
de les intégrer modifier dans le projet
de loi relatif à la justice du 21e
siècle qui sera présenté au printemps
2015 par la Chancellerie mais
pensez-vous pas que ce temps nécessaire
au dialogue et la concertation tant
demandé par ces professions évitera
ainsi de cristalliser les oppositions et
de renforcer les
blocages
répondre la parole est à Monsieur
Emmanuel Macron ministre de l'économie
de l'industrie et du numérique vous avez
la parole monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
d'abord je respecte et j'entends ces
professionnels du droit qui ont
manifesté hier je les ai vu reçu je les
ai vu avec la garde des saau et j'étais
hier soir avec certains d'entre vous
dans un débat avec les huissiers donc
quand on débat et qu'on veut échanger
sur des idées je suis toujours preneur
et à disposition et je m'étonne au
demeurant qu'on puisse manifester contre
un projet de loi le jour où il est
déposé là aussi vraemblablement sans
sans en avoir véritablement pris
connaissance mais qu'importe qu'importe
c'est la vie po dans laquelle nous
vivons au final alors monsieur le
sénateur moi je voulais vous poser une
question en est-il des réformes comme
des économies c'està-dire que vous en
voulez toujours davantage mais vous êtes
toujours contre celle qu'on fait et donc
il en serait il en serait des réformes
mais les bonnes sont sans doute celles
que vous n'avez pas fait pendant 10 ans
monsieur le sénateur mais les réforme
c'est toujours la même chose c'estàdire
c'est faites les réformes ailleurs mais
pas chez moi et c'est ité mais si
faudrait pas les faire et donc les
réformes ça ne serait pas chez les
professions réglementées ça devrait être
chez les salariés ça ne devrait pas être
ici ça devrait être chez les autres ça
n'a pas de sens et donc l'esprit
l'esprit de ce projet de loi c'est quoi
c'est de débloquer la société française
partout où elle peut l'être c'est de
moderniser les conditions de notre
fonctionnement partout où ils peuvent
l'être et en l'espèce je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire que c'est un projet
qui est uniquement porté par Bery en
aucun cas le Premier ministre l' redit
ici il l'a dit hier ce projet est porté
également par la la garde des sauts
défendu par la garde des sauts et
préparé avec elle et préparé avec elle
et si vous regardez le le texte qui a
été déposé hier elle est le garant de ce
dispositif alors maintenant revenons
précisément sur ce dont il s'agit parce
que finalement ce ce que vous défendez
in concretto c'est l'existence
intangible d'intérêt acquis et bien moi
je vais vous dire parlons concrètement
sur l'emploi la liberté d'installation
que nous proposons régulée qui ne
déstabilise ni les territoires
ni les professionnels en place elle
permettra de créer plus elle permettra
de créer et c'est garanti dans le texte
plusieurs offices notariax elle créera
de Cré elle permettra de créer de
l'activité de l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi aujourd'hui il y a rien qui
justifie monsieur le sénateur dans le
système où nous vivons il n'y a rien qui
justifie que dans notre République
l'emploi et l'entrepreneuriat soit
réservé à quelques-uns donc oui j'y
crois je crois que on peut préserver
l'égalité la sécurité juridique parce
qu'elle est préservée par ce texte de
loi je crois qu'on peut préserver
véritablement les fondements de notre
République qui est préservé dans ce
texte de loi et en même temps créer de
l'activité réformé parce que la réforme
elle doit être partagée par tous parce
que l'effort ne vaut que s'il est
partagé par tous c'est comme ça que ce
sera
efficace la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Alain Marc pour le groupe Union
pour un mouvement populaire vous avez la
parole mon cher collègue merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui a répondu
d'ailleurs en partie à un précédent
collègue sur le même sujet monsieur le
ministre laavon a connu au même titre
que d'autres départements du sud de la
France l'héros l'OD le Var et les
Pyrénées Orientales des intempéries
d'une violence inouie il y a quelques
jours je tiens à saluer ici la
mobilisation exceptionnelle des secours
pompiers gendarmes policiers mais aussi
la qualité de l'action des bénévoles qui
par solidarité et avec efficacité sont
intervenus auprès des sinistrés la ville
de Saint-Afrique par exemple a subi des
inondations catastrophiques d'une
importance jamais connue dans l'histoire
de celle-ci qui a 9000 habitants vous
avez été très réactif monsieur le
ministre en prenant quelques arrêtés de
catastrophe naturelles pour que les
biens assurés bénéficient de cette
procédure et je vous en remercie au nom
des populations concernées toutefois
toutefois nous apprenons ce matin que 10
communes de laavon je je vais rapidement
les citer coupiaque Tournemire ser de
Cernon la Basti Pradine brousse le
Château combré La Panouse de cernom
Martrin saint-bosélie saint-juerie n'ont
pas bénéficié de l'arrêté de catastrophe
naturelle à ce jour je sais que vous
allez faire le maximum monsieur le
ministre pour que soi résolus ces
problèmes qui apparemment sont d'ordre
technocratique le plus rapidement
possible nous ne comprendrions pas en
effet que ces communes qui ont subi des
dégâts très conséquents ne soient pas
retenu attendons une réponse de votre
part sur ce sujet pour ceux qui est des
biens non assurables des collectivités
locales touchées par ces intempéries les
dégâts se chiffrent pour un département
comme le mien comme la Verron à
plusieurs millions d'euros il s'agit du
patrimoine routier les chaussées les
ponts 3 à 4 millions d'euros pour le
seul conseil général de laavyon mais
aussi des stades et bien d'autres
infrastructures pour les communes et
communautés de communes monsieur le
ministre nous en appelons à la
solidarité nationale que ce soit à
travers le fond de solidarité ou
peut-être la detetr vous avez récemment
annoncé avant les intempéries une
augmentation sensible de ce fond au
niveau national l'urgence et la gravité
de la situation pourraiit-elle permettre
que cette augmentation nationale soit
fléchée vers les départements qui ont le
plus souffert de ces événement
climatique d'une grande violence même si
ce n'est pas la vocation initiale de ce
fond merci pour vos répondre la parole
est à Monsieur Bernard casen ministre de
l'Intérieur vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre oui monsieur le sénateur
vous m'interrogez sur les inondations et
les intempéries qui ont eu lieu dans
laavyon avec certaines communes qui ont
été particulièrement touchées je pense
notamment à la commune de Saint-Afrique
dont vous venez de parler à l'instant
j'ai souhaité que au Conseil des
ministres qui a suivi immédiatement ces
intempéries on puisse prendre l'arrêté
catastrophe naturelle de manière à ce
que l'indemnisation des collectivités
concernées puisse être effective dans
des délais brefs mais vous avez raison
de dire que cet arrêtée catastrophe
naturelle a permis à 23 communes de
pouvoir être inscrite comme susceptible
d'être indemnisé et qu'il en reste
encore quelques-unes qui n'ont pas été
retenu j'ai indiquer à certains de vos
élus que dans les 10 jours qui viennent
il pourra être procédé à un examen
attentif de la situation de ces communes
de manière à ce qu'aucune qui a été
victime de ces intempéries ne soit
laissé sur le bord du chemin et nous
devons faire en sorte sur les 23
communes de laavyon plus celle la
dizaine qui reste encore en cours comme
sur les 178 communes des autres
départements qui sont concernés par ces
arrêtés de faire en sorte que les
financements interviennent rapidement
poser une deuxième question qui est
celle de la dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux dont le premier
ministre a annoncé qu'elle sera
augmentée de assez significativement
pour 2015 et vous me posez la question
de savoir si on peut affecter cette
dotation au collectivités locales qui
ont fait l'objet d'unempéri il y a deux
éléments de réponse à cela premier
élément de réponse il appartient au
préfet en liaison avec les collectivités
territoriales de déterminer les
conditions d'allocation de ces fonds
dans la plus grande concertation avec
les élus c'est le sens des instructions
que je leur ai donné plus
particulièrement dans les départements
touchés par les inondations et
deuxièmement il est souhaitable et
possible de cumuler la dotation
d'équipement des territoires ruraux avec
le fond calamité et le fond catastrophe
naturelle dans une limite de 80 % de
taux de subvention pour les
collectivités locales concernées voilà
donc quels sont les règles vous pouvez
constater qu'elles
permettent une concertation avec les
collectivités une indemnisation dans de
bonnes conditions à cela s'ajoutera les
mesures que j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure
à votre collègue Colomba c'est-à-dire
une réformme du processus catastrophe
naturelle car ça ne sert à rien de
passer rapidement les arrêtés en conseil
des ministres si le temps après les
arrêtés est aussi significatif que celui
qui existait avant le procédure
accélérée ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
fusionner les fonds des avances
augmentées des
inspections plus simples et un niveau
d'avance plus significatif pour
permettre aux collectivités locales
d'être indemnisé avant même la
présentation des factures pour celles
qui sont les plus affectés par ces
catastrophes naturelles
merci la parole est à Monsieur Antoine
Caram pour le groupe socialiste vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue merci
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire d'État
chargée de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche le Conseil ministériel
de l'Agence spatiale européenne de napes
en novembre 2012 a abouti à l'accord
pour Arian 6 cet accord historique
prévoit de développer un nouveau lur
sans passer finalement par Arian 5 ME on
le sait la France est à la pointe de
l'Europe pour le spatial par ses
entreprises du secteur son engagement à
renforcer les investissements et les
projets mais c'est aussi grâce à la
Guyane et au centre spatial de courou
que nous pouvons offrir le lanceur le
plus fiable du monde cet accord couronne
la dynamique que vous avez enclenché
grâce au cospace que vous présidez avec
les ministres de la Défense et de
l'économie vous avez réuni l'ensemble
des acteurs de cette filière pour
constituer ce qu'on pourrait appeler
l'équipe de France du spatial avec
l'agenda stratégique horizon 2020 vous
avez remis l'état sa place de stratège
pour donner du sens aux projets de
recherche qui sont essentiels pour
l'avenir il y a quelques jours le monde
se tournait vers la se filae succès
majeur de l'AL le knè les laboratoires
et les chercheurs qui ont contribué à sa
conception c'est un signe fort de
l'investissement pour la recherche et
nos universités ce signe fort doit être
sanctuarisé et renforcé mais madame la
ministre permettez-moi aussi de rappeler
que la Guyane attend plus d'engagement
de l'État et les guyanais ont besoin
d'actes concrets et rapides que dire au
guyanais qui a quelques kilomètres de
courou n'ont toujours pas accès à l'eau
potable ou à l'électricité et encore
moins à Internet et au réseau mobile que
leur répondre quen faut d'aménagement la
circulation des biens des personnes est
toujours extrêmement difficile faut-il
rappeler encore que le taux de chômage
est trois fois plus important qu'au
niveau national et qu'un jeune sur sur
deux est sans emploi il y a vous le
savez un grand paradoxe en guyan d'un
côté le centre spatial de courou fait
levier d'attractivité de l'autre les
infrastructures qui ne suivent pas le
développement démographique de la région
ne sacrifions pas donc le développement
de la Guyane sur l'Hôtel des réductions
de déficit on ne comprendrait pas
cararian 6 soit toujours comme le disait
François mitteran une fusée lancée sur
fond de bidon ville et que le
déséquilibre territorial entâche l'image
d'une réussite du spatial anguan pour
conclure Madame la Ministre pouvez-vous
nous indiquer les retombées attendues en
terme d'emploi et de compétitivité pour
nos entreprises anguyan je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est Madame
j forasso secrétaire d'État charg de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche vous avez la parole madame la
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Antoine Caram tout
d'abord je tiens à féliciter l' emble
des équipes d'Arian espace et ducness
qui ont réussi avec succès le 63e
lancement d'affilé d'Arian samedi
dernier à
courou alors vous l'avez dit monsieur le
sénateur le le Conseil ministériel de
l'Agence spatiale européenne lzard a
pris le 2 décembre à Luxembourg une
décision historique celle de développer
un nouveau lanceur Arian 6 sans passer
par Arian 5 ME qui remplacera Arian 5 à
comptter de 2020 dans un univers vous le
savez est extrêmement concurrentiel et
nous nous devions de réagir au niveau
européen cette décision est aussi le
fruit de l'engagement sans faille de
l'ensemble des acteurs du public et du
privé que nous avons voulu réunir avec
mes collègues jean-v ledriillant et
Emmanuel Macron dans un conseil commun
le cospace et qui a permis de donner un
nouveau lanceur avec des spécifications
qui conc qui qui convenaient absolument
à tout le monde à tous qui nous
permettaiit d'être concurrentiel et qui
de plus convenaent à la fois au vol
scientifique au vol stratégique et au
vols également commerciaux donc c'était
extrêmement important que nous prenions
cette décision c'est un lanceur
modulaire et compétitif qui nous
permettra de rester en tête au niveau
international après un effort de
conviction absolument déterminant auprès
de nos partenaires allemands cette
décision prè au Luxembourg représente
pour la filière des lanceurs l'ensemble
de la filière un investissement de 10
milliards d'euros de 8 milliards d'euros
dans les 10 années à venir et de 4
milliards d'euros pour les la seule
filière Arian 6 en ce qui concerne le
Centre Spatial guyané il a pu à son
démarrage être en effet considéré comme
une enclave sur le territoire guyané
vous l'avez rappelé mais aujourd'hui la
situation a changé et 75 % du personnel
est constitué de du centre spatial est
constitué de personnel guyané il
représente 9000 emplois directs et
indirects 15 % du PIB du territoire ce
développement profite donc directement
au guyané je rappelle que près de 75 %
des personnels je l'ai dis sont locaux
et que 30 à 40 % des appels d'offre
bénéficier à des entreprises guyanaises
le fait d'avoir décidé de lancer Ranis
va nous permettre de faire un
investissement dans les années à venir
de 600 millions d'euros à kurou en
Guyane les entreprises seront concernées
et les collectivités territoriales avec
nous devront davantage former les jeunes
c'est pour cela que l'IUT de courou
développe des filières de formation au
spatial et d'ailleurs le président de
l'IUT n'est autre que le directeur du
Centre spatial de courou qui s'engage
également financièrement par ailleurs
l'université de guyan a été créé pour
renforcer la formation et permettre aux
jeunes de bénéficier de cette filière du
spatial qui est une grande filière
d'avenir merci madame la
ministre nous en avons fini avec les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
merci mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h15 pour l'examen de la proposition de
résolution relative à un moratoire sur
la mise en œuvre des ple des questions
d'actualité les dernières de l'année
2014 il est temps pour nous de refaire
la
séance